next billion users or envy you are
countries where half of the population
or more is not connected yet to the
internet they have a different way to
interact with the Internet a different
way to use their smartphone and we're
going to highlight you all those cases
in this presentation first let's have a
situation on the ground as you can see
the next billion users has spread out
three different continents Asia Africa
and Latin America for some of them
Internet is just the beginning of a new
era we usually think about the next
billion users as something in the future
something which is not ready yet I've
shown on the map numerous countries
already parts of the internet some
countries in Asia as a whole region
account for 50% of the smartphone market
Vietnam Philippines Indonesia the the
part of the Southeast Asia which account
for 350 million users on the internet
and India itself accounts for 40 million
new users every year again we usually
think as the next billion users that we
have a time line we have a time to think
about it it's already big it's already
present and just continue to be bigger
and bigger in the upcoming years for
them phone is not only a device to
connect to the Internet is the only
device that will have access to you so
you should not expect your users you
have access to your computer or tablet
to access Europe like your applications
they have a mobile-only mindset and as
an example Nigeria has only 11% of the
population having access to a computer
they have an instant for Ubiquiti
computing in India 30% of the search
made on Google are using voice it's not
an edge case it's not a power thing a
power user thing to do there it's really
normal they have natural interaction
with the smartphone they will use it in
all the possible ways lastly they have a
youth demand for localized content
English is the first language on the
Internet but doesn't mean it's a
language understood by all the users
over there they don't only want
translated content they want counter to
adapt it for them for that culture the
environment also you should expect users
to change their language quite often
based on the environment it may be at
work with family with friends based on
that current location they would just
continuously change language it's not
something rare for them it's really
often as shown on the map numerous
countries who are nbu a part of Asia and
Africa both continents accounts for a
hundred nineteen of fishel languages in
India you have three hundred and three
hundred and fourteen million people who
can speak two languages and sometimes
even more again in India you have 23
official languages written in 13
different scripts it brings some
challenges in terms of content display
and font swapping Hindi which is one of
the official language in India is not
even on the top 30 language in the web
even though it's the fourth most spoken
language around the world
Nigeria itself as a country has 500
spoken language around the whole country
even though English may be the official
language there people will use their
local language because again it's part
of their culture you cannot deny that
also they have another diversity in
terms of hardware they will have
different devices different brands and
you have to account for them whenever
you're developing your application some
of them you may already know so some OMS
obviously Samsung is there it's also
some Chinese OMS as quite way Oppo
oneplus show me in Nigeria you have also
everyone and in India you have Micromax
Trenton is the first Android go om
around the world and maybe you never
heard of it they have commonly lower
specs device but you should not target
only those you should think about it as
a spectrum some people may have higher
spec device
some of them lower and you have to
account for all of them lastly they have
a long wear hardware upgrade you should
think about it whenever you estimate
your operational cost
developing an application targeting
those markets we usually think about
offline as a narrow state during the
plane in a train in a building where the
signal is not strong well actually it
can be a choice for them offline usually
is just a temporary mistake the way we
think about it in Western countries but
in those nbu countries ninety-five
percent of the users are on prepaid plan
even though 4G and 3G is definitely
cheaper years after years people just
turn it off whenever they don't need it
so whenever you're showing a banner
you're not connected well they already
aware of it they are the one who set it
off also Wi-Fi is not always reliable so
you can't expect people to
download resources over Wi-Fi because
they may not have it at home sometimes
40 is even faster than Wi-Fi some
websites may may be also offered for
free on mobile plans are restricted by
government regulation so whenever you're
integrating with third parties think
about it whenever you are developing
your apps targeting those markets we
usually think about diversity as a
problem as just too many parameters to
account for we would love just to have
one single standard but that's just
denying their diversity we think
diversity at Google is not a problem
it's an asset it's a growth opportunity
for your market as shown earlier again
many countries who are which R&B is a
part of Asia which already account for
50 percent of the smartphone market and
will account for 50 percent of the
upcoming growth on the smartphone market
you have to compare that to mature
markets like Western countries where you
have already huge penetration of
internet and smartphone access over the
next 1.6 billion new connection 40
percent will come from these top five
countries four of them are next billion
users Nigeria India Pakistan and
Indonesia also the surrounding countries
will be affected by that growth so again
think about it
the next billion users are already there
and they're just waiting for your abs to
be compatible with them now I'm gonna
hand over to my colleague Rajeev Amer
it's my bad
it's going to talk about improving your
application by adopting Google products
that can help you to do that - um right
thanks Jessie hi everyone my name is
Omri Sanjeev I'm a developer advocate at
Google based in India and in this
section I want to talk about some of the
Google products that you can use in
order to help give a better user
experience for your users in the nvu
market let's start with AB bundles app
size is a key factor that users consider
when they install an app in these
markets by switching your upload format
to app bundles you allow play to
distribute an apk that's optimized in
terms of resources code and languages
based on your device's configuration
this helps greatly reduce the initial
install size of the application and also
the installed friction that users have I
want to call out an example here Red Bus
which is a ticket booking app from India
who switched over a bundle format and
reduce their apk size by 30%
this in turn helped them increase their
conversions by 6 percent and the best
part of it is that they didn't have to
change a single line of code to achieve
this result to optimize even further you
can choose to deliver functionality as
on-demand rather than package it all
together in the initial install this can
be achieved by using the on demand
feature with a bundles
by adopting on-demand features you not
only reduce the initial install size but
also the space that you actually take on
the device a lot of users run out of
space on device in these regions
regularly the other important factor is
that based on usage you can choose to
remove modules and save X pace for the
user an example I wanna call out is
Paytm who initially reduced their app
size using app bundles and then further
optimized by removing some of the F
modules as on-demand modules and reduce
the app size by a further 20% and they
have not done yet they have
making further changes and improving on
this number even further to extend this
even further you could use conditional
modules to install certain modules based
on your device configuration or users
locale during the initial install let me
explain this with an example for you
guys assume that you have an app which
you want to release it to two different
countries but in each of these countries
you have completely different payment
instruments to support which would mean
that you would have completely different
workflows assets and library is required
for realizing each of the payment
workflow one way of doing this would be
to package all of this into a single
payment module and at runtime decide
which workflow to show to the user the
depending on which local he is using the
app from with conditional modules you
could actually separate this into two
different modules and during install
time decide which module needs to be
packaged with the app so that based on
the user's looking that way your device
would only get the portions of code and
the workflow that it will ever use the
additional the second payment module
will not be there at all
as I mentioned when new countries have a
lot of official languages for example
India has 23 official languages but the
interesting thing here to note is that
users usually set their device language
to be English and it's a very common
practice for applications which cater
for these markets to have an in-app
setting where users choose the language
for localizing content on their app now
when you take AB bundles for instance
are bundles uses the device language to
optimize in what language resources need
to be packaged along with the apk during
installation and with language splits
API you actually break the best of both
worlds using this API the developer can
then fetch additional language resources
for different languages say when the
user is selecting a new
language from the settings I talked
about in Sawle sighs for some time let's
talk about how AB upgrades happen in
this region app upgrade cycles are
usually longer which means you will end
up having situations where you will have
more versions of your app in the real
world to support this has side effects
it not only increases your operational
cost but you will have to deal with
situations where users negatively rate
your app for bugs you have already fixed
but they're still experiencing it
because they never upgraded it now in
app upgrading API helps you fix some of
these problems it allows you to show a
dialog to the user
informing them that a new update is
available the best part of this API is
that it actually takes into account the
play targeting rules before showing it
to the user that is if your stage
rolling out to only 5% of your users
only those 5% of users actually see the
upgrade dialogue it's the same case with
people who are in a different channel
say your alpha Channel of your
application and you release only to
alpha only those users will actually see
this I wanna now switch over to SMS
two-factor authentication is very common
in nvo countries this this is because a
lot of payment modules are actually two
factor of the digression based and more
and more applications are requesting for
SMS permission to ensure that they can
make the OTP flow much more super
smoother by Auto filling it for the user
but with growing privacy concerns a lot
of users are reluctant to give this
permission and also worried about how
much information they are passing to an
app by giving them complete access to
their SMS inbox last year we introduced
SMS retriever API which kind of solved
this problem to a good extent where an
OTP message could be passed to an
application without the user giving this
permission but it required the SMS
message to be formatted in a
to be more precise it neither hashcode
towards the end of it which allowed the
API to identify that the particular OTP
message is for a particular application
that's great when the SMS is sent by the
applications servers but it imagine a
case of a bank application they have to
deal with hundreds of applications or
other thousands of them and in such
cases you will have to do a look-up on
and to figure out which or which hash
code has to be attached to the end of
the message before you send it out to
the client and that's kind of
inefficient so that's where the SMS
consent API comes into picture the
workflow remains pretty much the same
but in this case when the OTP is
actually received on the device that so
TP messages will be on the device the
system would recognize using some smarts
that a this is an OTP message and sure
dialogue to the user asking him
permission to pass that message to the
application if the user approves it the
OTP message is passed to the application
and the rest of the flow can
automatically continue the advantage
here is that there is no additional
formatting required
there's no SMS permission required for
this I want to call out an example here
of Zomato
which is a food delivery and restaurant
booking app from the region which was
able to remove SMS read permission
completely from their application by
using this API they were part of our
early access program and they've
reported to us that their user flow has
now improved in speed and users are
having a much better experience because
of this moving on to real-world
performance no matter where you're
launching your app understanding the
real-world performance of your app is
really important
once you ship it but it's even more
critical in NGO markets because of the
plethora of devices available there and
a wide range of conditions hardware
network situations prevalent in these
regions
five is performance monitoring SDK is
one such SDK that you can add to your
app which will then collect statistics
automatically visualizes it and even
identifies and highlights problems for
you this allows you to fix problems
before users actually see this giving a
better experience for your users
I want to highlight the work that Ola
Capps trade with data that they actually
derive from this firebase
performance consoles they were able to
reduce their apps cold startup time by
50% for users on the 2g network and this
gave a great experience for those users
and they use the data that was
visualized by firebase console and
identified an issue with which was
particularly happening on 2g networks
and fix this immediately giving a better
experience for the users and lastly I
want to talk about localization when we
talk about localization a lot of times
people think about the language in which
the content is shown on the device or
within the app now that's absolutely
important no doubt but there are other
things that you can do in this aspect
you could use things like localized
graphics and store listings based on the
user's language and play console this
helps improve conversions for your app
we have recently introduced country
based targeting which again is targeted
towards using targeted towards improving
user X user conversions for your apps
one of our early access partners
cookbook actually increase their
conversion rates by 17% using this
feature if you want to understand more
about what they did didn't excellent
blog about it and you should check that
out and lastly on a call out that this
is not an exhaustive list of products
you can use I've only called out a few
of them here which basically have given
a lot of advantage to some of our
partners who cater for these regions now
I'd like to hand it over to my colleague
rajeev who talked to you about how to
optimize apps for low-end devices thank
you
what are you ready thank you thanks I'm
late
hello everyone my name is Rajeev Kumar I
walk on Android group project and
hundred go is a platform for devices
running 1gb or less ram minimum eight
gigs of internal storage and low end CPU
cores today I'm going to talk about some
of the best practices that me and my
team has used to optimize apps on disk
to optimize the apps on RAM and I'm also
going to talk about some of the
techniques we use to keep app responsive
so let's talk about apk size why does
apk size matters it matters because it
impacts the time it take to load your
application it also impacts the RAM it
takes to load your application and it
also impacts the battery it takes to
load your application so what can you do
to reduce your apk size on disk use Pro
guarding it really helps we have used
providing on system apps like launcher
and Bluetooth apk and just by enabling
Pro guarding we were able to gain around
25 percent of disk space but this year
to whitelist your public API in ProGuard
the flags file so that you don't wipe it
out with pro guarding so how can you
learn more about your apt a structure we
have used epic analyzer tool to look at
what part of application is contributing
to the apk size and let's say you didn't
mine the apk size was bigger because of
the resources you would be able to use
shrink resources together with minified
enable in your Android studio project to
reduce your apk size signify
gently what else you can do you may
consider to use a specific density for
example you can target mdpi for certain
devices and therefore not include
resources for higher density as I
mentioned the app bundles could also
help to reduce your apk size or your
initial download size let's take an
example the Photos app can have the
viewing capability as well as the
editing capability you may decide to not
include editor to begin with and we only
download the return module when user
clicks on the editing part of the
application you may also use consider to
use reduce set of languages in your
application and therefore your resources
is going to be smaller and apk size is
going to be smaller as well continuing
on a team of reducing your apk size
let's talk about the image size in your
application how can you reduce image
size in your application consider
compressing PNG and JPEG crunching PNG
file and if possible use WebP a file
format which is great on saving the disk
size and has a decent rendering
performance you may consider to use
vector graphics for resolution
independent icons and a scalable media
by doing so you would not be including
the static resources and therefore your
apk size is going to be a smaller what
else you can do avoid innovation a
single enum can take up to one to one
point four kilobytes size in your
classes the Dex file if possible use a
tin definition with pro guarding and it
will replace your enumeration with
integer constants remove debug symbol
from your native boundaries the
great for debugging your application
however it can take significant amount
of apk size then wired extracting native
libraries by doing so you would be
instructing package manager to not to
copy dot so5 from your application to
the file system and as a nice side
effect your update size is going to be
smaller now I'm going to talk about how
to reduce your app size in RAM so how
would you monitor your a half size in
RAM use Android profiler which comes
with Android studio to generate heap
dump for your application you may also
use the adb command which is a DB cell
AM dump heap to generate Java heap dump
as well as native heap dump and with the
debug version of your application and
with these heap terms you would have
pretty good idea about what part of your
application is contributing to the RAM
size so let's say system is under memory
pressure what can you do to reduce
memory pressure on the system for this
the activity manager service provides a
callback call on trim memory which you
can implement in your activity and can
release resources and cache objects to
reduce memory pressure on the system
what else do not create unnecessary
processes unless they assort lib a long
live processes can't contribute to the
memory of your sister application use
services aspiring ly if possible
consider using Java Scala which is
constraint aware it can take into the
account the system memory pressure the
network conditions as well as the
battery consider using optimized data
container which are are a map array set
a sparse array
vast boolean array longest partial rate
these are optimized for using me more
efficiently and can save your app to
have less RAM size continuing on the
theme of reducing apk size in RAM you
should consider avoiding memory chance
by reducing the number of garbage
collection events to occur and to do and
for this you should avoid allocating
objects in the performance critical area
of your application and those areas are
on layout on draw one major etc
I talked about reducing the memory churn
by reducing the number of garbage
collection it not only impacts the
memory but it also can impact your app
responsiveness by eating your a-frame so
now in this slide I'm going to talk
about how to keep your app responsive
and for that start with do not drop data
let's say you are an email application
in which user was composing an email and
some other application shows on top in
this case you want to save data so that
when your application comes back again
on top you want to restore data so that
user does not lose data do not expose
raw data consider using content provider
which is the consist consistent way to
sell your data across application within
your application as well do not
interrupt user consider not to call a
start activity from broadcast receiver
or from a background service if possible
consider using notification manager to
set up a notification to which user can
come back to your application by looking
at that notification got a lot to do
consider doing in a thread maybe you
know in a background thread to avoid any
to avoid any long-running processes
running in your main thread if possible
you may also consider to use the job is
good ler for the processes which are
going to take longer duration as I
mentioned earlier it is constrained
aware and can experience job when system
is available for processing your job do
not our load single activity for the
devices of devices you may consider your
acting your application as a federation
of activity and by doing so you would be
you would be making your application
more maintainable and I just nice side
effect it will work well with the
negation history and the back stack
model
continuing on the theme of keeping your
app responsive design your UI so that it
works with different screen sizes your
resources your images to the scale up
and down based on the screen sizes and
lastly do conserve device battery a
mobile device is not so mobile if it is
constantly connected to the wall charger
two of the main contributor of the
battery drain are the processor and the
radio signal so it's important to do
add little processing as possible and to
use network as infrequently as possible
now this brings the end of our
presentation but by no means this is the
exhaustive list of techniques and best
practices you may use in your
application to learn about the full list
of practices and techniques you can go
to developer.android.com slash
performance we hope this participation
may have helped you to learn more about
the techniques you can use for making
your next your application available for
next billion users thanks a lot
[Music]